We conclude the Odyssey today and as we
discussed uh last lecture, the Odyssey
is really about a homecoming about three
members of a family uh Odysius Penaltz
who after 20 years separation must come
together again and rediscover their love
for each other. And as we discussed last
class, all three suffer from depression.
Um, Odysius suffers from post-traumatic
stress disorder because war has
shattered his identity, his sense of
self, his worldview, his purpose.
Penelpi
um is depressed because the love of her
life has disappeared and she doesn't
know if uh he's dead or alive. Tamakz is
a teenager, a young man who cannot
inherit his father's legacy or his
mother's wealth. Okay. So all three are
depressed. And today we will discuss how
love
uh brings the three together and
resurrects all three. All right. Okay.
So a major topic that we will discuss
throughout the semester is the idea of
love. What is love? How does it manifest
itself and why is it so important? Okay.
So remember that
consciousness
is the universe. Okay?
And our consciousness is uh infinite.
But we don't know that because in order
to navigate our reality, we hallucinate
time and space. And time and space makes
us believe that we are separate from
everyone else when in reality we are
unified with everyone else. Okay. So the
reality that we see is a a hallucination
created by our ego. Okay. And our ego
makes us believe that we are separate
from each other. And love is the force.
Okay. Love is the monad
god
or love
that burns in us and compels us to
return to the monad and which is which
reminds us that we are all
interconnected. Okay. So love is the
force that compels us into unity. And
when we meet someone that we truly love,
we move together
back to the monad. And within the monad,
our love is imprinted.
And this love
um becomes a force onto itself that
compels us back into it. All right? So
in other words, um, Penelopey
and Odysius
are in love with each other and they and
as a result, no matter how far away they
are,
they still are drawn back to each other
because they complete each other. Right?
So another way of saying this is that
because our consciousness is infinite,
okay? It exists in even dimensions. We
can break our conscious into three
planes. Okay, there's a plane of the
mind.
Okay, our conscious
subconscious mind. Okay, and we are
aware of this. But then there's the
spirit,
okay, which is basically the heart, our
emotions, how we feel. And then at at
the very core of our conscious is the
soul.
And all three planes exist at the same
time. And when all three align or
correspond, we are happy. We know who we
are. We know what we should do. But when
all three split apart or they are in
conflict with each other, this creates
the idea of cognitive dissonance. And
this leads to trauma and depression. And
that's the issue that uh Odysius,
Penelpi, and Tamakas face where they're
in their soul, okay?
They know that they're all alive and
they will all return to each other one
day, okay? But in their spirit they
because of the distance they have a
sense of depression because they are
away from each other and in their mind
they logically believe that
uh auditions is dead and audition
believes that I can never return home.
Okay. So there is a disunityity of these
three things and for
the family to reunite they also must
combine all three together. Okay, does
that make sense? Right now these three
different planes believe different
things. There's a different narrative
and they must combine this narrative
into one complete worldview if they are
to come together as a family. That is
the struggle uh within the Odyssey. That
is the journey of the Odyssey.
All right. Okay. So, um the main idea
that I want you to understand is that
love is a unity of all three and love is
the burning of the soul.
Okay? In other words, what love
ultimately is is intimacy.
How do you know if you love someone? You
love someone not because
you think about this person all the
time. Not because you obsess about this
person. You want to possess this person.
You love this person.
uh you know you love this person if you
understand this person intimately. Okay.
So in other words, you're able to
communicate
um and understand each other in an
intimate language with code words and
secrets. You understand secrets.
Okay? Does that make sense? All right.
So let's look at this concretely. Now,
last class we read um
uh Tamakus visiting Sparta where Helen
Troy and her husband King Manalas live.
We discuss how the two don't actually
love each other. We know because they
don't speak to each other. They say
words, they tell stories, but they don't
really hear each other. Okay? So for
example, the example is that uh Helen,
Menelas, and Tamarakus, they all get
drunk and Helen is telling stories of
Troy and she tells a story of how
Odysius infiltrates Troy and he's
disguised as a beggar but but because
Helen is the smartest person in the
world, she sees through his disguise.
She bathes him and then Odysius tells
her about the chosen horse and then she
helps the Greeks implement their plan.
And so she's a real hero of the story.
Okay, this is a story she tells herself.
Um she doesn't really think about the
reaction of Menalos who's lost um his
brother Egamenon and his friend Achilles
and other many other Greeks because of
the children of war. Okay. She doesn't
really care about his feelings. She
doesn't really hear him and he doesn't
really hear her. Okay. So, after she
tells the story, remember menas tell
tells a different story which is Helen,
you almost got us killed because when
the children horse came into Troy, you
came and you tried to trick us into
revealing ourselves by calling names of
our wives in their voices. And it was
only Odysius who saved us but because he
clapped our mouths. Okay. So basically
they are shouting at each other but they
don't really hear each other and when is
telling the story Helen just drifts
away. Okay. So this is not love.
They are together because they're stuck
together. Okay. Now what what now we're
going to see a different version. Okay.
We're going to see what love really is
like. And so what's what's hap what
happened is that Adysius is disguised as
a stranger and returns to Ithaca and he
um he plots with his son Tamakus.
Tamakus actually knows who he is but no
one else knows who he is. And right now
in his house it is overrun by suitors.
Okay, there's dozens of them who are
trying to wait for Penelopey's uh hand.
But Pump doesn't really tell them
anything. So they just sit around and
eat all the food that they can. Okay?
They get drunk. They sleep with a
servants. They um they make a mess of
things. Okay. And Odysius goes as a
beggar and they just and they abuse him
as well. But Penelopey hears that
there's a stranger in the house
and he she also hears that
um um he's he knows that her husband
Odysius is still alive. So she's curious
and she asks the beggar Adysius to come
to her apartment so that they can
discuss. Now the problem is this. The
problem is that the house is full of
servants and some of them are spies to
the suitors and this is is disguise has
disguised himself because he's afraid
that the suitors if they knew um who he
really was it would kill him but he also
doesn't really trust Penelope. Okay. He
doesn't really know how she feels about
him after 20 years because really he
abandoned her, right? So, um they have a
conversation,
but it it's a conversation that happens
on three different planes, right? The
mind, the spirit, and the soul. At the
soul level, they both know who each
other are right away. Okay? Okay?
Because they've been communicating
um multi-dimensionally.
So at the soul level, they know the
truth. At the spirit level, they are
afraid of each other, but they long for
each other. At the mind level, okay,
this is really important. At the mind
level,
they don't know who who each other um
are because if they did, they all be
dead. Okay, the suitors discover who
Adysius really is, they would kill
Adysius. Okay. So, this conversation
between Penelope and Odysius is the
first conversation they've had in 20
years. And this conversation is going to
happen at three different levels. Okay?
So, you need to analyze
um the conversation at these three
different levels to understand how love
works.
All right? So, remember they're talking
each other, but they're are servants.
And these servants, some of them are
spies for the suitors. Okay? So there's
an public public language and there's a
private language all in the same time.
Okay. So um Penipley asked the stranger
Odysius, prove to me that you actually
know my husband. Okay. So uh can you
read uh Ivory?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh good woman Adysius the great master
of subtlety returned. How hard it is to
speak after so much time apart. Why,
some 20 years have passed since he let
my left my house and put my land behind
him. Even so, imagine a man as I portray
him. I can see him now. King Adysius. He
was wearing a heavy len cape, sea
purple.
>> Okay, stop. Okay. Um,
keep going.
>> In double f fold with a a golden brooch
to clap it. Twin sheets for the pins on
the face. A work of art. A hound
clenching a dapsel fawn in its front
paws. Slashing it as it rifts. All
marvel to see it. Solid gold as it was.
The hound slashing, throttling the fawn
in its death throws. Hooves failing to
break free. I noticed his glossy tunic
too, clinging to his skin like this,
like the thin glistening skin of a dried
onion. Silky, soft, the glint of the sun
itself. Women galore would gaze on it
with relish. And this, too. Bear it in
mind, won't you? I have no idea if
Adysius wore these things at home, or a
comrade gave him, as he boarded ship, or
a host perhaps. The man was loved by
many. There were a few aans to equal
him. And I I gave him a bronze sword
myself, a lined cloak, elegant, deep
red, and a fringe shirt as well. And I
saw him off in his long bench ship of
war in the lordly style. Something else.
He kept a herald beside him, a man a
little older than himself. I'll try to
describe him to you best I can. Round
shouldered. He was sworthy, curly,
curlyhaired. His name, Eurabates, and
Adysius prized him most of all his men.
Their minds worked as one. His words
renewed her deep desire to weep.
>> Okay. Her words renewed her deep desire
to weep. Okay? Meaning that he her his
words moved her spirit, moved her heart.
Okay. Now, you read this and you have
absolutely no idea what's going on. And
in fact, no one know what's going on.
The servants, the suitors, they might
overhear this, but they have absolutely
no idea what's being talked about. But
these words are able to move Penelope to
tears because she now feels her heart
stirring. She now feels as though her
heart is alive again after 20 years of
being dormant. Okay. Why? The answer is
that in this language
there is a code. There is a great secret
that only Adysius and Pelpy know. Okay?
And you you can't actually find it
yourself. But I'll tell you what it is
and it's the word brooch. Golden brooch.
Okay. This reveals that this person
speaking must be auditious. And the end
and the reason why is look at the detail
uh on the face of work of art a hound
clinging a double film. It goes on and
on and on and on. And what does this
poetry reveal? This poetry reveals that
this brooch is prized. This brooch is
embedded in the imagination of Odysius.
So what is this thing? This is a thing
that 20 years ago Adysius is about to
set sail to Troy right
says says to Adysius
the prophecy says you'll be gone for 20
years 10 years in Troy 10 years lost at
sea now says I know and prophe says take
this with you it's a golden it's a
golden brooch okay take this with you
and promise you that you'll return this
to me and what He says yes. Okay. Now he
get lost at sea and he loses the boat.
But what does he bring back? He brings
back the memory
of their departure together. And this is
what the words reveal. Okay? It's
impossible to see. All right? And it's
something that you will have to discover
for yourself. But I'm telling you right
now what this is, right? So this is an
example of the mind, the spirit, and the
soul, the language working together.
Okay? And now Penelopey in her spirit
knows this must be Odysius.
Okay, not the mind. The mind is still
stuck in the present but her soul has
always known. Now her spirit knows. All
right. And then after this conversation
where Penelopey is moved by her spirit
to acknowledge that her husband is still
alive, they can call a plan to kill all
the suitors. And the plan is this.
Penelopey will announce to the suitors,
listen, it's been 20 years and it's
about time I get married and get out of
the household. So, I'm going to have a
competition. Whoever wins this
competition, I will marry. Okay? And the
competition is this. Now, this is has a
bowl.
Um, if you're able to string together
this bowl and shoot a target, then I
will marry you. Okay? And the great
secret of course is that there's only
one person in the whole universe who can
string together this bow and that of
course is Odysius. No one else can do
this. So the shooters don't know this.
So uh there's a competition. All the
shooters try their best but they can't
do it. And then Odysius who still
disguises the beggar says let me try.
Okay. And the shooters are like what are
you talking about? You're just a stupid
beggar. Get out of here. But somehow
this is is able to try and of course he
strings together the bull. Okay. And
this is the climax of the epic the
Odyssey. Okay. So we'll read it
together. All right. Can can you um read
it Ivory?
>> So they mocked
mastermind in action. Once he'd handled
a great bow and scanned every inch. Then
like an expert singer skilled at liar
and song, who strains a string to a new
peg with ease, making the pliant sheep
gut fast at either end. So with his with
his virtuoso ease, Adysius strung his
mighty bow. Quickly his right hand
plugged the string to test his pitch,
and under his touch, it sang out clear
and sharp as a swallow's cry. Horror
swept through the suitors, faces
blanching white, and Zeus cracked the
sky with a bolt, his blazing sign, and
the great man who had borne so much
rejoiced at last that the that the son
of cutting cronis flung that omen down
for him.
>> "Okay, keep on reading."
>> He snatched a winged arrow lying bare on
the board. The rest still bristled deep
inside the quiver soon to be tasted by
all the feasters there. Setting shaft on
the hand gripped drawing the notch and
bow string back
right from his stool just as he sat but
aiming straight and true. He let fly and
never missing an axe from the first ax
handle clean on through the last and out
the shaft with with his wade raised
headsh shot free. My son. Adysius looked
to Telamacus and said, "Your guest
sitting here in your house has not
disgraced you. No missing the mark.
Look, and no long labor spent to string
the bow. My strings not broken yet. Not
quite so frail as the mocking suitors
thought. But the hour has come to serve
our master's right. Supper in broad
daylight. Then to other rebels, song and
dancing, all that crowns a feast." Okay.
So remember the main
um problem
uh conflict in the Odyssey is that
Odysius his worldview is shattered. His
sense of identity purpose is shattered.
He went to Troy to fight for justice to
fight for family to leave a legacy for
his son. But instead he he ends up
destroying families. He ends up causing
a war cry and he's too ashamed now to
face his son. Okay. So this passage
where Odysius
uh assembles his bow and shoots a
target, what it represents
metaphorically is a resurrection of his
soul, his worldview. Okay? The alignment
of his mind, his soul and his spirit
which makes him invincible. now. And
what allows him to assemble the bowl?
What allows him to resurrect his his
identity, the love of his son and the
love of his wife, right? Because he
first needs to um
know if Penipe still loves him or not.
And he knows because they when they talk
they're able to understand each other
intimately. Okay.
So now what's what will happen is it's
almost as though
um a normal person is now transforming
into a Superman. Okay. And because
um he knows he's fighting for right,
Zeus
um gave him a blazing sign. Okay. So now
that he has resurrected himself, the
gods look down and rejoice and smile
upon him and he knows that finally he
will fight for justice, for family, for
his son. Okay? And and even though uh he
and Tomas are heavily outnumbered, they
basically kill everyone.
Okay?
All right. So now after the su are dead
uh Adysius has a problem which is he now
has to reveal himself to Penelope. Okay.
So in the soul level they are together
again. At the spirit level they're still
together. They're now together again.
The mind at the mind level it's harder.
It's hard. Okay. Because how does
Odysius explain to her why he was gone
for 20 years? How does he explain to her
that he was in disguise all this time?
Okay. So,
um let's read this passage to see how
they reconcile themselves. Okay.
>> All right. So, this is Penoli um who who
is still distant. Okay. This is has
revealed himself but Penelope has got
conness. Okay. She's still depressed and
she doesn't yet want to admit to in her
heart that her husband is still alive.
Okay. All right. So, she's keeping
distance from him. So, he basically
tells um her maid uh your to make a bed
for
for Adysius. She's still not comfortable
with him. So, they'll sleep in different
chambers tonight. Okay.
Come your move this sturdy bedstat out
of our bridal chamber. That room the
master built with his own hands. Take it
out now. Sturdy bed that it is. And
spread it deep with fleece blankets and
lesser throws to keep him warm.
>> Okay. So, you know, I'm you know you
it's all a shock to me. Odysius. I know
you're my husband, but you've been gone
away for 20 years. So, I would feel much
more comfortable tonight if you slept
somewhere else. Okay. So, we're going to
move your bed and move it uh move it out
outside and and we'll cover with nice
blankets.
All right, keep on going.
>> Putting her husband to the proof, but
Adysius blazed up in fury, lashing out
at his loyal wife. Woman, your words,
they cut me to the core. Who can move my
bed? Impossible task, even for some
skilled craftsman. Unless a god came
down in person, quick to lend a hand,
lifted it out with ease, and moved it
elsewhere.
Not a man on earth, not even at peak
strength, would find it easy to prize it
up and shift it. No, a great sign, a
hallmark lies in its construction. I
know. I built it myself. No one else.
There was a branching olive tree inside
our court, grown to its full prime. The
bowl like a column, thick set around it.
I built my bedroom, finished off the
walls with good, tight stonework, roofed
it over soundly, and added doors. hung
well and stuck sugly wedged. Then I
chopp I lopped the leafy crown of the of
the olive clean cutting the sun bear
from roots up.
>> Okay, keep on going.
>> Pling it round with a bronze smoothing
ads. I had the skill. I shaped it plum
to the line to make my bed posts. Bored
the holes it needed with an with an
augur. Working from there, I built my
bed start to finish. I gave it ivory
inlays, gold and silver fittings, wo the
straps across it all gleaming red.
There's our secret sign. I tell you our
life story. Does the bed my lady still
sandplanted firm? I don't know. Or has
someone chopped away that olive trunk
and hold our bed set off? Living proof.
Peneli felt her knees go slack. Her
heart surrender. Recognizing the strong
clear signs Odysius offered. She
dissolved in tears. rushed to Odysius,
flung her arms around his neck, and
kissed his head and cried out. Cried
out, "Adysius, don't flare up at me now.
Not you. Always the most understanding
man alive, the gods. It was the gods who
sent in sorrow. They grudge us both
alive in each other's arms, from the
heady zest of youth to the soup of old
age. But don't fault me. Angry with me
now because I failed at the first
glimpse to greet you, hold you so."
In my heart of hearts, I always cringe
with fear some fraud might come beguile
me with his talk.
>> Okay, so again, this is a secret
language. This is an intimate language
between Odysius and Penelpi. On the
surface, it seems as though Penelope is
just testing Adysius. Are you really my
husband? Do you really know that this
bed is something that can't be moved?
And this says, "Yes, I know." Okay,
that's the public. Okay. But at the
subconscious level, at the spirit level,
what what this conversation really is
about is Penelopey is saying to Adysius,
you know, 20 years ago, you abandoned us
for glory in war. How do I know that if
we let you back into our life, you won't
seek adventure again? You just won't run
off and uh go to war to seek eternal
glory. Now this is says that this bed is
my heart. This bed is something that I
worked really hard to create with loving
care for years and years and years. And
this is where my heart is. The bed is my
love for you and it cannot be moved
and it's something that is the
foundation of who I am. So I will never
ever leave you again. I will make my
home here with you for all eternity.
Okay.
All right. And so what we now see is f
finally the alignment in Penelope
between mind,
spirit, and soul. And that makes her
alive again. Okay. All right. Now she's
happy. She flings herself around Adysius
and acknowledges the love of her life
has returned.
Okay. So the last thing I want to
discuss with you is what really is the
purpose of life. So
um while on his journey, Odysius travels
to the underworld and he meets Agamenon
and Achilles. Okay. And Adysius and
Achilles have a conversation. Okay.
Okay. Can you read? Uh I agree.
>> Yeah. But you Achilles, there's not a
man in the world more blessed than you.
There never has been, never will be one.
Time was when you were alive. We argues
honor you like a god. And now down here,
I see you lorded over the dead in all
your power. So grieve no more a dying
great Achilles.
>> Okay, so this brings us back to the
Iliad, right? Remember in the Iliad
um the Iliad is about Achilles and
Achilles tells everyone that I came to I
came to Troy because I was giving a
prophecy. I could either die
um an old man who no one knows back at
home or I could die young as a great
hero in the shorts of Troy. And of
course that's not really a choice. Of
course I want I want to be famous. Of
course, I want people to celebrate me.
Okay, so he he goes to Troy. He kills
Hector, proves he's the greatest warrior
in the world. The Greeks celebrate him
and then he dies. Uh and the source of
Troy as is prophesized. Okay. And so
Adysius meets Achilles
and Adysius says to Achilles, Achilles,
you must be so happy down here because
everyone worships you. And just as
everyone worships you back in our world,
you've accomplished everything that
you've set out to accomplish, Achilles.
You must be so happy with yourself,
right? And then Achilles says,
>> I reassured the ghost, but he broke out
protesting. No winning words about death
to me, shining Adysius. By God, I'd
rather slave on earth for another man,
some dirt poor tenant farmer who scrapes
to keep alive, than rule down here over
all the breathless dead. But come tell
me the news about my gallant son. Did he
make his way to the wars? Did the boy
beame become a champion? Yes or no? Tell
me of noble Pelus. Any word you've
heard, still holding pride of place
among his meron hordes? Or do they
despise the man in Helis and Inia
because old age has lamed his arms and
legs? For I no longer stand in the light
of day, the man I was comrade in arms to
help my father as once I helped my our
armies, killing the best fighters Troy
could field in the wild wide world up
there.
>> Okay. So Achilles responds and says,
"Adysius, I'm dead now. So now I can
look at my life in its entirety. I can
now for attorney consider what is what
is important, what is purposeful, what
gives us meaning and purpose. And I
discovered like you know what I regret
my life because I should have died an
old man my family rather than go die
young in the shores of Troy because
being dead I asked myself what makes me
happy and what makes me happy are the
memories of my father the memories of my
son that's what I care about that's the
purpose of life that is what gives life
meaning Okay. So that is the ultimate
sto the ultimate moral of the story of
the Odyssey which is to say that we are
here to seek love because love is what
gives meaning and purpose to our our um
lives. So to construct a family to build
a family that you can love is much more
important. It will give you much more
happiness than building an empire than
being the most famous person in the
world. And this story, this legacy is
what will become the foundation of Greek
civilization, which is humanity's
greatest civilization. Okay.